معالي الوزير ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لانضمامك إلينا. من الجيد أن أكون هنا
يبدو وكأنه مكان مثير للغاية ، لذلك
نحن نتحدث عن التحول الرقمي بشكل
صحيح وتحويل
اقتصاد الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
ما الذي يعنيه ذلك بالنسبة لك كوزير للذكاء الاصطناعي
عندما تكون  بالتفكير في
مستقبل الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، فلنتحدث عن
الإنترنت والاتصال أولاً ثم
نفهم كيف يلعب ذلك دور
4g وفقًا لبعض المحللين الذين خلقوا
تكلفة الفرصة البديلة للاقتصاد الأمريكي
بحوالي 800700 إلى 800 مليار دولار أمريكي.
إنشاء
شركات مثل شركات uber مثل
airbnb وغيرها من الشركات التي تستفيد من بيانات نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS)
على أه تعرف بيانات الإنترنت أو
الاتصال بالإنترنت وبيانات الاتصالات
معًا في جهاز واحد ،
سيكون لـ 5g تأثير بتريليونات الدولارات
ليس فقط على الولايات المتحدة ولكن عالميًا
كيف يمكننا ضمان  أننا كدولة
نستثمر في البنية التحتية اليوم لنكون
قادرين على أن نكون لاعبين في هذا المستقبل
للمضي قدمًا ما نعرفه هو أننا نريد أن
نكون أفضل دولة  ProjectSyndicate ar حيث يتعلق الأمر
بنوعية الحياة التي تمضي قدمًا ، لذا فأنت
تفكر في التأثير الاجتماعي الذي تفكر فيه في
التأثير على الأعمال ، ومن ثم فأنت تعرف تمامًا
التفكير في كيفية دفع القطاعات بشكل
صحيح ولكن بالنسبة للعديد من الأشخاص ،
لا يزال الذكاء الاصطناعي نوعًا من الأشياء المجردة  أعجبني
نعم ، إنه نوع من الحدوث ، إنه يتم
التصفية من خلال حياتنا ، كيف
يمكنك تحقيق ذلك ، ما
هي الأشياء التي تراها والتي كان
لها تأثير كبير في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
فلنلقِ نظرة على الطرق المختلفة التي
يتم بها نشر الذكاء الاصطناعي إذا نظرت  في مجال النفط والغاز ،
على سبيل المثال ، يتم نشر الذكاء الاصطناعي في
قطاع النفط والغاز في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
للتأكد من أنه إذا لم تتمكن من التحكم في
سعر النفط ، يمكنك نشر الذكاء الاصطناعي لجعل
تخزين توزيع إنتاج
النفط لديك أفضل بكثير وكانت العمليات
أفضل بكثير حتى تتمكن من
تحقيق مكاسب في الكفاءة ستُترجم إلى
تقليل تكلفة البرميل
وزيادة هوامش الربح ، لذا بدلاً من
محاولة إملاء الأسعار ، دعنا
نحاول تحسين عملياتنا وتحسين
رؤيتنا من البيانات التي لدينا
وخلق المزيد بأقل من ذلك إذا
قلت فقط وصف ما سيكون عليه
العيش في الإمارات العربية المتحدة في السنوات الخمس إلى
العشر القادمة ، ما هي التغييرات الأساسية
التي تعتقد أنها ستكون
حقيقة واقعة
لذا
فإن أول شيء أود قوله هو
أنني لا أعتقد أن التكنولوجيا ستكون
في المقدمة ، أعتقد أن التكنولوجيا
مع تطورها وتحسنها ستكون
منتشرة للغاية وستكون مخفية
للغاية وما سنراه هو أننا
سنرى  سيكون البشر قادرين على القيام
بعملهم بشكل أفضل ، وسيكون
لديهم الكثير من الوقت بين أيديهم
وسيكونون أكثر سعادة وهذا هو
الهدف النهائي الذي نهدف إليه
كحكومة هو استخدام كل هذه الأدوات
سواء كان ذلك  blockchain أو أي
تقنية أخرى لتحسين حياة الإنسان في
دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ولتحسين الحياة ليس فقط
للسكان المحليين من كل شخص
والمقيمين والسكان المحليين والسياح من خلال
التكنولوجيا لذلك فإن التكنولوجيا هي وسيلة لتحقيق
غاية والنهاية هي سعادة
الناس لذلك
أنا  اعتقد  لقد تم إثبات أن الخمسين عامًا الماضية
يمكن القيام بها ليس فقط
للشرق الأوسط ، بل يمكن القيام به عالميًا بحيث
يمكنك أن تكون دولة ناشئة يمكنك أن يكون لديك
قادة مستنيرون يمكنك
وضع رؤية تجذب الأشخاص من
200 جنسية للعمل معًا.
وتزدهر من أجل مستقبل أفضل
ليس فقط للاقتصاد المحلي ،
دبي والإمارات العربية المتحدة اليوم هي مركز للاقتصاد العالمي من
حولها بشكل جيد ، ويسعدني أن
أكون جزءًا من الرحلة ، ويسعدني أنك
شكرًا جزيلاً لك أيها الوزير العظيم  لرؤيتك